so we are researching or our newest film
journey to the South Pacific we came
across this incredible story of this
floating classroom called the Columbia
for us is the perfect tool to really
take audiences to these amazing places
in Raja Ampat
I'm Walter Amir one of the teachers on
Columbia we travel to our 132 village
around Raja Ampat the kids are so
excited when we arrive I am probably the
only Western presidents on this ship
really the most important element from
the beginning is having local
instructors so not only in Division but
actually from Raja Ampat who speak one
of the 17 different languages that exist
in the region there's another element to
I mean having these local older brothers
and sisters the kids in the villages
feel inspired you know this is their
family
what's really exciting about how the
Calvillo teaches the kids is they do it
in a fun way in one scene in particular
they showed how the coral polyps reach
out and grab food so what we were able
to do with that is both show this really
fun interactive game but then transition
to what it actually looks like on the
reef these kids have essentially grown
up in the water playing every morning
jumping off the dock and even though
they've been water babies from birth a
lot of them have never had the
opportunity to use a mask and actually
see everything that is on the reef and
we try to take them to spots where
there's a very good example of a healthy
reef but we also take them to some
damaged areas so they can see with their
own eyes the the difference between
those healthy reefs and those damaged
reefs here in Raja Ampat singing and
dancing are very important to our
culture we sing about everything on the
Columbia we teach the children songs
about protecting the reef and to have
pride and love for the habitats in our
backyard in the villages that we visited
and we've come back to again to hear the
fact that they're out there singing the
Columbia songs we haven't been in this
village for two years and we come back
and they're still singing those songs
that they learned aboard the Columbia
it's getting this close right now it's
pretty it's pretty thrilling that is
incredibly rewarding
what's cool about the Cala BIA is that
it teaches the Islanders how important
their reefs are and what they can do to
protect their reefs and that's something
that I think we can all take as a lesson
for everywhere that we live